so we have to go through the the water
in order to get to the village but don't
worry because we have a boat and we have
a boat Rider
they look very joyful is a very joy free
to bury prey that's welcome fancy so
just have a lovely swim with a swimming
lesson and now the children are showing
me where they live many of the village
children are orphans
so the grandmothers of the village have
learned to sew in order to try and make
a living
double this is the toilet
it is soil in some logs you'll notice
some of the children have got bloated
stomachs and this is a result of
drinking the dirty lake water this
little fellow is looking for a second
helping but there just simply isn't
enough food and these children only have
one meal per day
by jungle 2wd go get you some little
magenta greenish okay I mean when I was
a kid and I used to say I don't want the
crusts and then we've got over 100 kids
here queuing up just for crusts
have you found some fruit he's found
some perfect the really crazy thing is
there's a massive lack of clean water
yeah it rains all the time and rainwater
is clean but there's no way of capturing
it so instead they go straight to the
lake and drink out of it so on the way
up this this hell I was slipping all
over the place and the children were
holding my hands to make sure that I
didn't fall over and I'm tired and this
is this is a big help to think that many
of the villagers have to carry 20 litres
of water on their head from the lake up
this every day is uh it's tough stuff
what's happened um from the work up to
the hill just very difficult so about an
hour so to get up from from the water
that doesn't look at balls cannot be fit
here because these are hilly areas so
there's no water dip instead of maybe
using a bore holes we can use water
tanks so this is a water tank where the
rain comes down and this water tank is
the rightful owner of this man here who
has no water problems yeah you so the
water leaks from the roof yeah into the
tanks yeah the tank fills up yeah and
then there's a tap here here which is
currently covered to stop everybody
drinking from it
this lasts throughout the summer yeah in
this claim compared to water from the
leg because there's a mesh inside so
there is nothing that can't get set
inside the tank for the materials for
this one how much how much of the
materials again sorry
$1,200 yeah on there okay the village
has many needs but their number one
priority is clean water to drink and to
watch
here in Uganda so I've just got back to
the UK had a life-changing experience in
Uganda and the first thing that we're
going to do is we're going to build a
massive water tank for the whole four
hundred villages which i think will be a
good start
and the plan will be to transform the
village over the community months and
years and if you'd like to get involved
whether that's by sponsoring the
projects or actually coming out then
please do drop us an email at info at
Samuel leagues dot-com